[Applause]
how you doing i'm good how you doing
i'm doing fine thanks for uh thanks for
being here thank you for having me man
this is my first time i know it's good
to have you did you check out my
you could sample my singing if you ever
want you just put that on a wrap right
a little that in there something sorry
not going to happen i didn't think so um
[Laughter]
come on he's got to make a career here
oh
ruin your career for conan now i have a
question for you you have a very
exciting life
and you obviously like performing uh
these
these crowds that are just so exciting
you get so much energy from them
now you're making films and this is good
news you have a great film career
it's people don't understand making
films is so boring
you know there's so much down time
there's so much that's not happening how
do you handle that that's a lot of
downtime i have to do something with my
time it's funny you should ask that
because actually
on a set of too fast too furious it was
so much downtime that i actually
i had to turn my trailer into like a
club and invite
extras over what do you mean what did
you do to your trailer to make it into a
club i call it club looter you see how i
went to walmart
right i got as many different christmas
lights got a little strobe light man and
just used every
every amount of juice electricity that
you could use and just turn my trailer
into a club
so you had music you had a good time
music going on there was cds i had
security pattern people down at the
front door
sounds like a very cool trailer i wish
i'd come by yeah you see you missed club
loader man
i blew it you blew it well when you and
i are working together on my album we'll
spend time together right
right right now uh i've heard that you
are a a
a aficionado of strip clubs that you
that you
consider yourself an expert on strip
clubs is this true first of all well you
see
i've been through i've been all over the
world you know yes i've traveled
quite a lot and i've come to like how
that has to be strip clubs i've come to
the
i've come to the conclusion that atlanta
georgia where i'm from has the best
strip club
see they know they got the best strip
clubs in the world yeah
they're just hoping we don't cut to them
yay i mean i wouldn't know
uh what is this strip club you speak of
uh okay what is it that you look for in
a in a strip
like what do you what do you want well i
mean of course the women first and
foremost the curves you know
how they shake they get it down to a
science you hear the newest music in the
club in atlanta georgia
um and funny enough the food is is great
with the food yeah a minute i'm telling
myself who's going to a strip club for
the food
telling you about your breasts out of
the way i'm trying to eat some lasagna
you can say that until you come to the
strip club and check out one of the
dishes man you got me i got to go
my wife will say you are not going i'm
going for the food honey
you could tell her that they have a
vinaigrette there i have to try
all right now you talk about the curse
what do you people want to know
what do you look for in a woman um of
course
intelligence confidence you know i kind
of know when i see it but the most
important thing is gotta have pretty
feet
are you serious pretty feet yeah not a
lot of guys say feet they don't go right
to feet but you like
feet i love feet it's like if you're if
your feet are messed up then just
wear boots please that's all i have
you know what i'm saying don't have them
out they're not right
okay all right what if a woman's just
dropped dead
unbelievably gorgeous smart talented but
then her feet aren't happening
we gotta we i can't really do much with
that man we gotta work we gotta work
with defeat somehow
okay let's say halle berry had uh had
bad feet what if halle berry
unfortunately had feet that weren't so
great uh-huh but she doesn't
that's what you don't know she has great
feet i've looked
i've peeped it out man everything are
you sure yeah
how do you know she has great feet
because i know you could look what do
you mean
now get going it goes so bad even if you
look in the magazines and they have
their toes out you can look and no but
they can airbrush that's you can't tell
that i've heard of people airbrushing
you know facial features i've heard
of them yeah brushing curves but i've
never heard of them airbrushing feet so
you know what you might be right
you know what we have one way to figure
this out which is halle berry was on my
show
a couple years ago and she's been she's
been on the show a lot she was just on
the show recently for x-men
but she was on the show a couple years
ago and she didn't wear shoes during her
appearance
and we can actually show that and we can
see what her feet look like let's get
there are her feet right there those
pretty feet
you think those are let's zoom in a
little bit zoom in a little bit let's
see how those looks
[Applause]
yeah we have very good camera work here
now i know i i would give i would i
would just give my left arm if i could
write a song
and i can't but i would love to do that
where do you write
your music the majority of my music is
written inside vehicles
actually while they're in motion while
i'm driving well you're driving so you
can
but what if you get a really good idea
for a lyric and you i mean you're
driving
yeah i mean i drive with my knees man
you know i can drive with my knees and
write
i know it's dangerous but it happens
yeah yeah a lot of the songs
so literally you'll just be there
driving with your knees writing a tune
writing a tune you know and if if it's
that serious then i just pull over
you know say it for a little while yeah
like i'm just going to pull over
right here and just turn i'm telling you
you got to get you got to get it down so
it's science man knee driving is getting
very popular these days
well the cops are looking for you now
for sure be on the lookout for the knee
driver ludicrous
uh all right well we're talking about
cars in uh too fast too furious
you you you know you get to be around
all these fast cars do you like to drive
fast
man i drive fast all the time really
yeah i love to drive fast i can't help
it
right well okay uh what's the fastest
that you've driven
um about like on the autobahn whatever
in germany
yeah you can you can't actually go and
there's no speed limit there is that
right no
not at all i think i went about 280
kilometers which i think is about
180 miles per hour if i'm not mistaken
it's just
cool to say i did 280 and leave out the
kilometers what'd you do about 280
kilometers
um wow i mean uh
wow okay yeah i mean i've gotten a
speeding ticket um before and basically
i was going over 100 i was in atlanta
georgia
the guy gave me a ticket i actually had
to go to traffic school because of it
and i didn't want to sit in traffic
school with like a bunch of strangers so
i had to recruit all my friends to come
sit in traffic school with me
and they all came with you they all took
the day off from work and just was like
all right we're going to go help them
out
i got i got friends that love me man
yeah that's nice so they came and sat
with me and
you know through the long time period
and we made it happen that is real love
when people will go to traffic school
with you it really is thank everybody
who came to traffic school with
now the the heart of the game you're
narrating
this and okay why do you think they they
chose you to narrate
man you know i've been told i have a
very powerful voice you know that
demands attention
a very good voice so they came to me i
laid it down made it happen
with no problem whatsoever very nice
okay so yeah and it must be nice going
through life with a voice like that
oh definitely you know i use my voice as
an instrument and as a tool all the time
right yeah but also just when you're
talking to the ladies it must be nice to
have a voice like that
of course i mean i don't know ladies
what do y'all think
my voice is always there you know kind
of way up here when i get talking fast
see i peeped it out i peeped your voice
out when you were singing over there
yeah
yeah so yeah you know yeah when i was in
like high school and stuff and i talked
to girls like hey you wanna go to the
prom what do you what do you think
did it work it was way up there uh no it
didn't work uh
then i'd knee drive home and it was sad
got a knee drive
no kids don't need drive ludicrous says
you got a knee drive
uh the heart of the game opens friday in
select
cities and uh thank you so much for
being here very good
friends stick around